did you and Jake ever do anything
together or no oh god well technically
technically I crashed my Southwest panel
uh of jankweiger as jankweiger yeah yeah
so I showed up and I was like yeah I'm
the real Jake weaker and uh and the
reason the reason I did this impression
is because they would pick on me when I
was this tiny YouTube channel right and
then once I grew big enough I was like
well let's do a debate you know because
they would pick on me they said no and
they all of a sudden I was like
Voldemort they wouldn't acknowledge my
name so I started what I would do is I
would do these young Turks parodies
where I would do impressions of them and
then uh I would actually like run them
back then as ads before Young Turks
videos
and they got really pissed he's watching
you as him yeah it's the most
embarrassed I've ever been in my life
but I just felt like I had to do it is
that him right there yeah yeah and
gained a ton of weight for the uh or you
put a person yeah
look how uncomfortable he is is that
okay so this okay
um
[Music]
foreign
would you have a conversation well again
there's a big difference between saying
I disagree and like calling me a Nazi
you know you're saying he's a garbage
and he's a horrible person and also like
misrepresenting you know what a big
thing is is they had um they missed they
said uh Stephen calls women you know
lying and he's sexist and and
they even break this whenever we tell a
joke on air like Joe what do I say if we
tell a joke that we know is going to get
some heat always make sure that there's
I said like 30 seconds before 30 seconds
the people have context yeah yeah
because people will go and they'll
afford you that right they'll look at
the context say it was a joke and I
think this was a joke with Christine
blasey Ford remember uh yeah which we
now all know is fake yeah it's 100 and
uh the joke in one of the monologues was
um something like of course Christine
blasey Ford uh authorities are
investigating and uh they're trying to
make sense of I don't remember exactly
the setup right verbatim but the story
which she the account that she gave to
the Washington Times which was different
from the account that she gave to her
therapist which was different from the
account that she provided to the
authorities of course they are still
open to the possibility that she's a
lying
that's still on the table yeah and they
said like Stephen calls women lying oh
yeah there we go right there yes sir no
no just a woman exactly specific
instance okay and so when they do that
like you know they're being dishonest
big time and but yeah I would but I was
sitting I was like I still think it's a
funny joke I think it's hilarious but
you know it's crazy but look at the
power of people just reading that that
didn't know what you said you're
automatically that guy yeah it was the
police yeah we had Jank here I don't
know six months ago what was the temp 10
months ago eight months ago no I think
it's about a year March really yeah
and I gotta tell you
it's very interesting I had no idea what
to expect when he came in I don't know
what direction was going to go we had a
very good conversation together and he
made his argument you know I made mine I
asked the questions you know he went
back and obviously you know politically
where he lies yeah and then we had the
uh Kyle kolinsky on uh four months ago
five months ago two months ago two
months ago great conversation we had
this uh David Pacman on young guy fiery
you know energized and you know he very
good uh and then who else have we had on
we had a bunch of these guys on just to
kind of see because we have plenty of
liberals on Me on the way on the show
they wouldn't do it for long and I
understand that yeah I totally
understand Roland Martin here yeah we
had Roland Martin here and it was it was
fireworks it was crazy we had uh Neil
deGrasse Tyson but that wasn't even like
a I just asked a question about covet
and that one will hold this One
Direction with the conversation with
covet well he believes that but but you
know what it is like I again who's your
customer who are you doing it for to me
it's two things one do you like doing it
I do I like talking to people and seeing
where it goes two who's the customer the
viewer listening and saying you know
what Pat you were wrong there okay let
me go do a little more research and you
know what that argument he has a better
argument than you okay cool or you know
what I don't know I don't know if I
agree with Kyle or Pac-Man great make up
your mind and then my argument your
argument gets better the audience is
winning yeah you know we're building
that relationship to say okay dude in
these three places we're way off because
I asked a question from uh David Pacman
who would consider himself well I don't
know politically where he would put
himself left taxes how much taxes is too
much taxes right and you go I don't know
30 and we were kind of on the same page
when it came down to taxes the most you
pay 30 percent okay I was like man flat
tax is a little bit better for me I had
the conversation with Jerry Springer and
Jerry Springer's like I'm like Jerry how
much taxes would you be willing to pay
I don't know what kind of a question
this is that's the question to me
politically yeah here's your budget go
spend it and stay tight and stop asking
me for more if you don't know how to
spend the money that I gave you that's
now 32 trillion dollars I don't know I
paid 90 in taxes I said you would pay 90
tax we're taller you pay 90 taxes I'm
like if you're like saying you pay 90
taxes why did you move your show from
where it was to Connecticut she's saving
the taxes you did this why did you do
why haven't you done it already yeah the
IRS will take your check and by the way
you know you know you know what's the
last question I asked uh Jerry I said
Jerry don't think about the Jerry today
that's worth 50. yeah think about the
Jerry that was making 50k a year coming
up would you be okay paying that taxes I
mean the perspective is you're taking
that fire away from the younger guy and
then that's when the conversation was
like I can't believe you're saying this
I don't know like I just enjoy having a
conversation with opposition I think I
think opposition brings leaks in our
arguments strength lengthens your
argument and then audience
we couldn't get people on the left to
really come on the show a whole lot and
it's not a debate though it was always
designed to be the Socratic method like
when we do debates we do debates uh on
the show I even debate uh right-wing
people like like Ben Shapiro Jordan
Peterson John style so all them I just
uh there's this character Skyler Chardon
it's called Devil's Advocate and I
always tell them like don't think you're
talking to Stephen Crowder like just no
it's not gonna be like I'm a liberal I'm
stupid which a lot of conservatives do
this character of people on the left
libt I'm going to yeah exactly I'm going
to present the strongest arguments
possible and sometimes they've been
tripped up and there's some funny stuff
like we always every time they're
talking like I throw them off I'll be
smoking a bigger Vape is that a segment
yeah Devil's Advocate yeah and we ended
up with problems because then
conservatives like this one's pretty
tough because it's like again I'm like
arguments because it's for the audience
for them to be and it was ridiculous
Clips against you like did the left use
clip saying this is what Crowder said or
no no no no no okay
I'm dressed up in an outfit with tattoos
in a coexistence
um
but
but all you know what my prep was my
prep for that was the mirror image of
Change My Mind
so I would go let me because I always go
claim truth flame truth what I most had
what I anticipate to be the most likely
claims and change my mind is not a
debate it's meant to be the Socratic
method to encourage people to ask why
and the irony is that a lot of people
end up changing their minds but when we
do that I'll you know we'll sit down for
three four hours and it's just anyone
who comes down well that professors come
down sometimes we've had reporters and
people from television sit down
um and it's not just students but that
is exhausting yeah four hours our
biggest goal is not to tell people what
to think it's to teach people how to
think like go through this process and
make sure that you're not making the
mistake of being able to point these
things out like some of these guys we
just talked about Bill Maher and those
guys and still making the mistake of
thinking that's the party to trust
because there's something that's broken
in the way that you think about these
things critically and go oh my gosh I
don't trust them for this this or this
but I still am going to vote for him
like wait a minute how did you get back
over here yeah right so it's not just
changed my mind it's hey we're quoting
to you people on the left all of our
sources like if any of our researchers
people come to us with a source from Fox
News we throw it out immediately not
because we don't have Fox but because
it's like yeah we understand the talking
point we want to know what they are
saying so that we can tell our audience
here's what they're saying here's why
it's wrong think through this process go
to our website don't believe me go to
the website click on the link see what
the article says we're not making it up
and we always try and go if it's like if
it's a study we'll actually link to the
you know study that's there yeah or if
it's like a new poll we'll link directly
to rasby Center if it's the only time
we'll ever use a conservative source is
if it's an exclusively like conservative
story that they have a scoop on
um so most sources are leftists like New
York Times Washington Post and we
provide 30 to 60 every single day when
we do the shows yeah every day respect
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]